[Musique]
c'est curieux ça pourquoi j'ai fait ce
cauchemar la guillotine il ya sûrement
un rapport avec la révolution française
zap toit en 1789 bien jouer la fête
je crois qu'on est tombé en plein dans
le mille bonjour messieurs dames
vous allez ou d'un si bon pas et avec
nous m'ont garçon tu vas comprendre
vous avez un mariage ah bah moi je
dirais plutôt un divorce ne sais pas
d'où tu sors mais nous on a faim depuis
deux ans entre les inondations la
sécheresse et la grêle les récoltes sont
catastrophiques et le prix du pain a
augmenté de 50%
voilà et avec tout ce qu'on va payer aux
nobles l église 0 1
comment tu veux qu'on mange mais vous
allez divorcé d'avec qui avec vos
fourches avec les privilèges avec ce
régime qui nous assaillent d'impôts t'as
pas les recourants ça chauffe de partout
en bretagne en bourgogne en alsace en
provence vient avec nous au monde sur la
capitale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en quoi les énerve tout cela est ce
qu'on arrive c'est notre bon seigneur
l'aristo va lui dire deux mots passage
on va lui expliquer à rien non réclamées
seront toutefois me donner ça me
plairait si je comprends bien voulait la
tête du roi on n'a rien contre lui
on aime bien mais vous que ça change je
comprends plus ils savent pas ce qu'ils
veulent détrompe toi
à la veille de la révolution le peuple
ne réclament pas la tête du roi tout
juste vu thi limiter ses pouvoirs et
mettre fin aux injustices et aux
inégalités car la france de louis saez
vit sous un régime féodal le peuple
enfin le tir et a comme on appelle
croule sous le poids des impôts payés au
roi au seigneur et au clergé et pendant
ce temps à versailles on mène la grande
vie
certains nobles perçoivent même de
belles pension comme la comtesse de
polignac qui reçoit 500 mille livres par
an c'est mille fois le salaire d'un
ouvrier et pourtant les caisses du
royaume sont vides
cette faillite est dû surtout au soutien
de la france dans la guerre
d'indépendance américaine lafayette et
ses amis ont coûté cher pour lutter
contre les anglais bref il faut trouver
des sous les ministres du roi dans les
caire propose de faire payer l'impôt à
la noblesse qui bien sûr n'est pas
d'accord c'est pour ça que louis saez
décide de réunir les états généraux une
grande assemblée où sont représentés la
noblesse le clergé le tiers-état les
députés du tiers sont choisis parmi les
bourgeois car les paysans et les
ouvriers ne savent ni lire ni écrire
enfin le roi demande que l'on rédige
partout en france des cahiers de
doléances dans lesquels les français
font part de leur plainte
nul doute qu'en ce printemps 1789 on est
loin d'imaginer l'ampleur que va prendre
la révolution mais la colère gronde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et que signifie cette inclusion rollin
mes jambes alors mon bon seigneur on a
une bonne descente il va faire un gros
roule à vive tout madame et sur le passé
mars attacks en fauteuil j'ai rien faire
les amis du calme pas de violence mais
vous avez raison mon petit mort qui vous
n'avez rien fait et a fait pour nous
aider surtout sa majesté touche
peut-être une petite pension mais aussi
comme tous ceux qui sont dans les petits
papiers du roi hamad sur annoncé je
voulais sur moi je ne suis qu'un petit
marquis et bien mon petit marquer ça va
changer
vous aussi vous allez mettre la main à
la bourse notre bon roi a décidé la
réunion des états généraux
ça vous la coupe hein excusez-moi de
vous interromps quoi mais ça va lui
servir à quoi de réunir les états
généraux faire payer des impôts à la
noblesse et du clergé alors ça ce sera
un véritable tour de force de faire
payer la peau à nous non pas que ce
serait injuste
je ne dis pas ça mais moi j'y crois pas
allons-y pour les états généraux
alors vous vous paraissez drôlement
confiant simple question d'arithmétique
chaque ordre ayant droit à une voix ça
nous fait donc une voie pour la noblesse
une voie pour le clergé une voie pour le
peuple voulait bien nous en reparlerons
allez mes amis j'ai rendez vous avec ma
bonne amie olympe de gouges
autre point capital
si ça vous intéresse monsieur le marquis
je vous tiendrai au courant des
prochains événements mais ça va être
chaud
je crois que ton marque du mauvais sang
à sphère fred car dès l'ouverture des
états généraux la question du vote par
ordre ou par députés et posé avec une
voix par ordre
il est clair que le peuple n'avait
aucune chance de se faire entendre face
au clergé et à la noblesse dont les
intérêts sont souvent liés les députés
du tiers état vont donc réussir à
changer les règles du jeu
le tien refuse de se constituer en ordre
séparé selon l'ancien système
donc il souhaite que les deux autres
ordres se réunissent à lui devant leurs
réticences
finalement il prend les devants et
rejoints par quelques députés du clergé
la baisse le 17 juin 1789 il proclame
l'assemblée nationale le roi refuse le
vote par député il fait fermer la salle
des états généraux mais les députés se
réunissent dans la salle du jeu de paume
et jure de ne pas se séparer avant
d'avoir donné une constitution à la
france
c'est le serment du jeu de paume et puis
le 23 il ya une séance royal une espèce
de coup d'arrêt que le roi veut faire en
disant tout ça est nulle et non avenue
séparez vous dispersez vous en quelque
sorte et les députés restent en séance
leroy envoie son maître des cérémonies
et bayer lui répond pratiquement sans se
retourner
la nation assemblée monsieur n'à pas
d'en recevoir et louis saez finalement
va céder et il va de même déclaré bien
ils veulent rester [__] qu'il reste
mais le roi n'a pas dit son dernier mot
il renvoie son ministre necker qui
étaient favorables à la réforme des
impôts provoquant la colère du peuple et
ils concentrent autour de la capitale
trente mille soldats pour prévenir les
désordres à paris la peur et la tension
monte
citoyens j'apporte d'une nouvelle grave
j'étais au café deux fois au palais
royal j ai rencontré un certain camille
desmoulins un avocat qui arrive de
versailles
ils affirment que les troupes du roi
après par un massacre pour cette nuit
il parle même d'une saint barthélemy les
patriotes est alors alors camille
desmoulins est montée sur une chaise un
pistolet dans une main une épée dans
l'autre et il a crié aux à fred la
marseillaise n'existe pas encore
elle ne sera écrite quand 1792 six mois
bon il a de bonnes ton camille
desmoulins mais les armes
vous allez trouver ou aux invalides par
dix 3000 fusil et 12 canons ils sont
stockés
on n'a qu'à des stocks est allé la
poudre on l'a trouvé et à la bastille
par exemple à bonne idée à la bastille
allez mes amis tout ça va mal
[Applaudissements]
et attention ça devient violent le 14
juillet au matin une foule de parisiens
envahi les à malines pour s'emparer de
fusil de baïonnettes et de canons
[Musique]
elle était passée où fred tu es par
sortie mais je rêve ou quoi
vous êtes en train d'éplucher des
patates alors que l'huile sur le feu
mais vous faites quoi exactement
je m'appelle antoine parmentier je suis
pharmacien militaire je suis très
surpris que vous ayez reconnu dans ses
tubercules la pomme de terre c'est un
légume révolutionnaire vous savez la
patate un légume révolutionnaire
expliquez moi ça si vous saviez à quel
point j'ai du mal à faire savoir toutes
les vertus de la pomme de terre
elles sont très nombreuses et en ces
temps de disette elle serait un très
grand secours pour le peuple tout entier
non évidemment mais l'accord ne veut
rien savoir l'académie des sciences non
plus les et pourquoi donc
ils prétendent que la pomme de terre
transmet la lettre moi même j'en ai
consommé pendant un an chez les
prussiens
quand c'était prisonniers et je n'ai pas
la lettre toujours ça en tout cas vous
avez raison avec un bon cornet de frites
ou un hachis dans l'estomac le peuple
serait pas descendre dans la rue si
j'allais en parler au roi de voûte à
tête je vous emprunte quelques patates
je la rendrai avec intérêt vous savez ce
que vous êtes vous êtes nutritionniste
on voit monsieur parmentier nutri quoi
monsieur je me présente fred
représentant en agroalimentaire brayer
la maison breguet horloger docteur
guillotin représentant rasoir vous êtes
l'un depuis longtemps monsieur breguet
ouf je vous dire au moins depuis deux
bonnes heures
mais vous avez une montre magnifique
c'est une montre à gousset bien sûr
qu'elle est belle c'est une nouveauté
tout juste sortis de nos ateliers
le roi va adorer il adore les mécanismes
de précisions vous pourriez me l'a prêté
j'ai un copain aussi comme beaucoup la
mécanique ah bon enfin dans ce coeur je
vous explique
elle est automatique pas besoin de la
remontée à l'intérieur on a placé un
petit balancier quand vous entrez en
mouvement quand vous marchez par la
majesté le roi vous attend monsieur
braguette ah bah c'est dommage j'ai été
coupé
contrairement à quelques idées répandues
louis saez ne s'intéresse pas seulement
à la serrurerie il se passionne pour les
sciences en général et surtout pour la
géographie
il s'intéresse aussi aux affaires de
l'état mais là il se montre souvent
indécis influençable ça le passionne
beaucoup moins que son aïeul louis xiv
cet arbre très consciencieux très
travailleur et ça va avec
l'indécision qui reste quand même le 13
2 millions de sa personnalité
louis saez est aussi profondément
attaché à l'église ce qui lui posera
beaucoup de soucis lors des grandes
réformes révolutionnaires
je dirais qu'il est plus dévots que
religieux il est très soumis à rome et
au prêtre chose que ce n'était pas
sérieux
en fait son image a été ternie par des
nobles de la cour qui fait courir des
rumeurs son impuissance sexuelle le
doute sur sa paternité à la naissance du
dauphin ou encore les infidélités de
marie antoinette
ces privilégiés de la cour en quelque
sorte scier la branche sur laquelle ils
étaient parce que ce sont eux qui ont
vraiment ruiné l'image du roi dès avant
la révolution
grossière erreur
ça encore plus longue chez mon dentiste
au fait docteur guillotin vos rasoirs
ils ont deux lames ah non une seule
suffit mais ce rasoir comme vous dites
c'est le rasoir national qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire par là vous comprenez
je ne vois vraiment pas pourquoi les
criminels devraient subir des châtiments
différents selon qu'ils soient riches ou
pau qui font partie de la noblesse ou du
bas peuple
c'est totalement injuste la solution ça
[Musique]
si je comprends bien vous faites ça par
souci d'égalité vous êtes une sorte d'
humaniste mais je suis pour que tous les
coupables puissent mourir la tête haute
façon par les dr iota sa majesté le roi
vous attend docteur guillotin ses tuyaux
- fred que ce bon docteur guillotin
n'est pas du tout l'inventeur de la
guillotine l'engin a été mise au point
par l'un de ses confrères le chirurgien
antoine louis qui s'est inspiré
d'ailleurs d'une machine qui existait
déjà en italie avant la guillotine seuls
les nobles était décapité à la hache ou
à l'épée les misérables eux étaient
pendus ou écartelée c'est dans un souci
d'égalité que guillotin députés du tiers
état a proposé ce nouveau procédé à ses
collègues de l'assemblée
peut nous paraître bizarre de nos jours
parce que la guillotine a une image très
négative mais sur le moment c'était un
réel progrès et la première personne à
avoir été exécutée par guillotine est un
condamnés de droit commun qui a été
exécuté le 25 avril 1792 dans la cour du
carrousel est d'ailleurs un public a été
déçu parce que les gens ont trouvé que
c'était trop rapide
on peut
sa majesté le roi ne peut vous recevoir
aujourd'hui une urgence l'a appelée
grave j'espère non c'est la serrure de
la caf qui est bloquée voulu dire qu'il
ferait mieux de s'occuper des affaires
du pays
plutôt crée pas les serrures tenez
coupez-les en fines rondelles
vous lui ferez des chips et puis moi je
vais rejoindre des copains
non ça va ça les amis bonjour alors
comment ça s'est passé cette prise de la
bastille à bannu on a eu chaud une
centaine des nôtres sont tombés sous les
feux du marquis de launay mais il a
capitulé et ils ont promené sa tête au
bout d'une pique dans tout paris ah oui
mais la bastille est tombé et avec elle
tout un symbole royal le 14 juillet ça
c'est une date qu'il faudra pas oublier
de fêter au 14 juillet on n'a pas oublié
ce 14 juillet 1790
après avoir pris d'assaut les invalides
pour s'emparer de canons et de fusils
des révolutionnaires se rendent à la
bastille pour y trouver de foudre
mais pour parler tourne mal le marquis
delaunay gouverneur de la bastille fait
tirer sur la foule
il y à une centaine demain après quatre
heures de combats la forteresse tombe
aux mains des assaillants
la bastille c'est aussi un symbole ça
c'est très important
pourquoi c'est un symbole eh bien parce
que on peut y être interné sur simple
lettre de cachet du roi sur simple
documents écrits signés du roi sans
procès sans avocat
un symbole de l'arbitraire royal est
tombé louis saez est obligé d'accepter
tout ce qu'il avait refusé auparavant
il promet d'éloigner ses troupes de
paris et il rappelle necker aux finances
puis il vient à paris et accepté bon gré
mal gré de porter la cocarde bleu blanc
rouge
le nouveau signe de ralliement des
français des parisiens l'acclament des à
versailles c'est la panique
son frère le comte d'artois et d'autres
proches du roi sans fuite à l'étranger
[Musique]
chanter la mariée elle m'a dit que vous
défendre la cause des femmes
oui j'ai s'est désengagé dans le combat
révolutionnaire mais j'écris 12 pamphlet
cette année le dernier s'intitule est à
la france sauvée par les femmes
j'ai bientôt que ce n'est pas beaucoup
plus à nos législateurs
vous êtes journaliste en quelque sorte
oui si on veut mais on a interdit la
publication mon dernier journal qui
s'appelait pourtant le journal du peuple
olympe d'une artiste si les pièces pour
le théâtre enfin pour l'instant je passe
tout mon temps dans les tribunes des
jacobins et à l'assemblée ont fait de la
prise est quoi oui voilà de la politique
je lutte pour la liberté et l'égalité
et pour l'heure le pays va mal les amis
le chômage la misère ont mis sur les
routes des milliers de vagabond qui
pillent les campagnes qui brûlent les
récoltes et alors et alors
les paysans sont armés on dit même mais
c'est une rumeur que des mercenaires
étrangers auraient été engagés par des
aristocrates pour égorger les paysans
c'est la panique
écoutez moi les paysans pis les châteaux
ils brûlent les archives sa grandeur
je vous le dis ça sent la fin des
privilèges tiens d'ailleurs ça il
faudrait que j'écrive marca il paquet
devrait peut-être aller prévenir me bond
marqué à bientôt
dis donc
l'abolition des privilèges c'était quand
déjà la nuit du 4 août fred c'est dans
quinze jours c'est bientôt
je veux marquer
olala ça chauffe c'est le marquis
je le redis où êtes vous
remarquez c'est moi encore vous m'ont
tout pris
alors faites comme bon vous semble et je
suis pas mon vous terroriser je suis
venu vous raconter la suite des
événements je vous l'avais promis jeudi
de punir un petit peu plus tôt non enfin
au neuf
je peux vous dire ça va pas s'arranger
pour la noblesse dans quelques jours
tous vos privilèges vont tomber
non le servage ils s'arrogent les
corvées quand même justice seigneuriale
près et tous vos droits féodaux c'est
pas pour filmer si je vous l'assuré
mais comment vous savez ça mes sources
je peux même vous dire ça va pas
s'arranger pour le clergé
3 vous demande il avait porté la
nouvelle à mon ami le curé de notre
paroisse c'est bien pour vous faire
plaisir
mais en attendant j'ai passé un coup de
fil aux pompiers qui vous envoie les
canadair sinon tout va cramer fait
qu'écouter déconnade et a montré ce
qu'il a dit ça suffit les cadets
[Musique]
la grande peur gagne presque tout le
pays
à l'assemblée aussi les députés ont peur
en particulier la noblesse et le clergé
il faut agir vite c'est la nuit du 4
août 1789 il y avait eu des propositions
un petit peu extravagante qui consistait
de la part de très grands aristocrates à
dire et bien j'abandonne mon privilège
sur le droit de chasse je supprime et
corvées et c'est au bout du compte il a
été décidé
l'égalité de principe pour tous égalité
fiscale l'égalité devant l'impôt et
suppression des ordres dé dignité et des
privilèges dans cette folle nuit du 4
août toute la société de l'ancien régime
s'écroule mais en aucun cas la propriété
privée des menaces et même celle des
nobles les droits féodaux doivent être
racheté ce qui favorise les paysans les
plus riches
ça doit être là
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le curé jia pas me
confesser je vais vous parler j'étais
chez le marquis et je viens vous
informer que d'importants changements
vont bouleverser l'église par le moins
mon fils et bien voilà vous allez
devenir fonctionnaire mon père je suis
déjà fonctionnaires de dieu oui mais là
c'est fonctionnaires d'état pour combler
la dette du pays qui s'élève à 4
millions de livres il faut nationaliser
les biens de l'église nationalisée oui
nationalisée ils vont évaluer vos
presbytère vos couvent et tout le reste
ils vont les vendre à qui voudra bien
les acheter et en contrepartie ils vont
mettre en circulation des assignats
enfin je veux dire une nouvelle monnaie
libération ils font tous refusé en bloc
ça joue le déconseille mon père vous
pourriez être exilé voire pire
[Musique]
cette nature le curé bon moi je retourne
à paris
la nationalisation des biens du clergé
sera débattu à l'assemblée à l'automne
lille est proposée d'ailleurs par
talleyrand l'évêque d'autun et le
combler le déficit de l'état qui
augmente depuis le début de la
révolution il faut prendre l'argent là
où il est dans les coffres de l'église
l'assemblée décide de saisir les biens
du clergé pour les vendre en
contrepartie l'état prend en charge le
salaire des prêtres
[Musique]
tous les membres du clergé sont payés
par l'état 1200 livres
c'est la somme qui échoit à un curé de
campagne désormais donc qui devient au
même titre que les enseignants
aujourd'hui par exemple un fonctionnaire
et à la réforme ne s'arrête pas là
l'assemblée décide sans l'avis du pape
de changer l'organisation de l'église
par exemple les évêques et les curés
sont désormais élu par le peuple
c'est la constitution civile du clergé à
laquelle les prêtres doivent prêter
serment
puisque les prêtres doivent donner
fonctionnaires ils devaient donc prêté
serment à l'état comme n'importe quel
fonctionnaire et c'est là que le bât
blesse car le clergé dépend avant tout
de la papauté et l'on voit naître dès la
deuxième partie de l'année 90 une
tension entre le pape d'une part et la
l'assemblée nationale d'autre part qui
va déboucher à un divorce progressif et
donc lorsque ce serment est exigée eh
bien les prêtres se diviser en deux
catégories ceux qui prêtent servant bien
entendu qu'on appelle les prêtres jure
heures et ceux qui refusent ce serment
qui reste fidèle au pape qu'on appelle
les réfractaires
plus tard pendant la révolution
les prêtres réfractaires seront
poursuivies et persécutés mais nous n'en
sommes pas encore là
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen du 26 août 1789 ils l'ont
voté c'est le début de la démocratie
alors oui si tu veux barrot garde on
parle de liberté d'opinion de liberté de
croyance de liberté d'expression oui
mais ils ont oublié de parler de
l'esclavagé du suffrage universel de
l'égalité des sexes et j'en passe
t'as pas tort mais il parle aussi de
séparation des pouvoirs d'égalité civile
et fiscale entre les citoyens de
présomption d'innocence pour les accusés
c'est quand même pas rien tu vas voir ce
qu'ils vont en faire de tout ça ne faut
pas être pessimiste comme ça ça va pas
prêt d'en saluer ariane bonjour l'un pas
non j'étais en train de foncer tour à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
vous avez vu ils ont placardé partout à
wissant la mûre et bientôt on va pouvoir
afficher aussi la déclaration des droits
de la femme
non si mon ami oh là on a commencé la
rédaction c'est vrai elle est ici vraie
écoute un peu juste un passage parce que
j'ai rendez vous ainsi que 10 par
exemple
nul ne doit être inquiété pour ses
opinions même fondamental
la femme a le droit de monter sur
l'échafaud elle doit aussi avoir le
droit de les amis comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure j'ai rendez-vous à vue
c'est quelqu'un celle là enfin c'est
quand même que des mots tout ça au fait
c'est ce qu'on va faire pendant son
absence
on est allé lui demander du pain avec l
idée et tu sais pas on a pris en otage
et on l'a ramené à paris avec toute sa
famille
le boulot j'ai la plonge air et le petit
mitron sais pas c'est encore une femme
qui était à la tête des opérations
ne me dis pas que c'était toi j'aurais
bien aimé rire mais se termine de mairie
encore une sacrée bonne femme c'est
demain
5 octobre environ 8000 femmes venus des
faubourgs de paris décident de marcher
sur versailles
elles veulent obtenir du roi des mesures
pour ravitailler la capitale en pas
bientôt des milliers de parisiens les
rejoignent leur idée est de ramener le
roi et sa famille à paris pour le
surveiller car louis saez fait de la
résistance il refuse de signer le décret
sur l'abolition des privilèges et de
ratifier la déclaration des droits de
l'homme on le soupçonne même de préparer
un coup de force militaire la famille
royale doit se résoudre à abandonner
versailles pour s'installer au pilori à
paris louis saez devient l'otage des
parisiens tous ces déplacements sont
surveillés
j'aimerais bien voir ce que fait le roi
entre quatre murs
alors il est où le nouveau c'est pas
possible ça j'ai encore filer mumbai
dédièrent c'est pas dieu possible
il est là il est là dites moi que se
passe-t-il ici vous déménagez le palais
ou quoi il semblerait que notre bon roi
veulent préparer un pique nique avec sa
petite famille un pique nique je dirais
plutôt un bancaire et vu toutes les
bouteilles de vin qui l'emmène vous
écouter on se passe de brad flexion vous
penserez à prendre l'argenterie et qui a
demandé à la lingerie de préparer des
tauliers de domestique détenus
domestique pour le roi et sa famille oui
bon restez pas dans mes pattes maïté où
il semblerait qu'ils veulent préparer un
petit jeu un jeu à mon avis prépare
plutôt lent fuite
bon vous avez vu leur oui bon ça va oui
c'est l'heure je vais aller bordés sa
majesté bord de sa majesté
bah oui toutes les nuits je dors au pied
de sony au cas où on a besoin des
services tels étaient les moins un coup
de main faites moi un ne l'a alors vous
voyez je me fixe une petite cordelette
au ou trois nié comme ça y'a qu'à tirer
et sa majesté services et si c'est drôle
ça je suis son valet de chambre monsieur
je m'appelle lemoine c'est moi son homme
de confiance
bonne nuit aux moines bonsoir monsieur
j'espère que ce soit et vous vrir leur
lien à ce qui risque d'avoir des
surprises
et oui le 21 juin au matin lemoine va
trouver le lit du roi vide pendant la
nuit toute la famille royale s'est enfui
de paris
le roi décide de partir à montmédy
rejoindre les princes émigrés et leurs
armées dirigé par le marquis de bouyer
le roi était déguisé en valet de chambre
tout se passe apparemment très bien il
fait très chaud il sans doute pris du
retard sur la sur la route parce qu'il
s'est arrêté pour pique [__] un
pourboire ça on va beaucoup le raconter
après coup à la fin de la journée du 21
juin le roi arrive à sainte-menehould où
il est reconnu par l'aubergiste est
également maître de poste drouet qui a
des doutes sur l'identité donc le laisse
partir
mais va le rejoindre à varennes wilson
l'alertent et à varennes le roi est
arrêté dans l'épicerie auberge également
de monsieur sauce dès son arrestation
l'assemblée constituante le suspend ses
fonctions il rentre à paris au milieu
d'une foule silencieuse et méprisante
qui ne se découvre plus sur son passage
l'abolition de la royauté est désormais
à l'ordre du jour la compagnie fraises
c'est toi alors quoi de neuf chez vous
cissé qui nous a fait le film louis saez
aux personnes a été du pain il avait
laissé une lettre dans laquelle il
expliquait qu'il allait avec sa famille
à metz ses bons amis et qui reviendrait
quand tout serait propre et sec venu au
manu militari
ça changeait quoi tous à l'habitude la
pagaille chez de révolutionnaire
explique moi les cordeliers
tu sais ce canton et de marins ils
veulent plus entendre parler du roi
ils veulent une république les jacobins
eux ils sont plus modérés ne pas ils
exigent le départ du roi mais il veut le
mettre à sa place
un régent philippe d'orléans c'est son
cousin et à l'assemblée les députés ils
disent quoi ah ben on va demander aux
notes l on vient au locle
il fera doux doit savoir les députés
qu'est ce qu'ils disent à l'assemblée je
vole que la révolution s'arrête plus de
vagues
du coup ils ont même réussi à faire
voter ce matin même un décret qui
innocentent le roi il rétabli dans
toutes ses fonctions
si je comprends bien tout votre
révolution là attention enfin le sujet
sensible après la fuite du roi la
révolution se complique
cette fois louis saez père bel et bien
la confiance du peuple et les
révolutionnaires se divise sur son sort
le 17 juillet 1791 des cordeliers menée
par danton et mara appelle les parisiens
à se réunir au champ de mars pour signer
une pétition qui réclame la déchéance du
roi mais la manifestation tourne au
drame
le maire de paris veuille y décide
d'envoyer lafayette avec ses troupes
c'est à dire la garde nationale pour
rétablir l'ordre et la fayette fait
tirer dans la foule
au bout du compte il y a une
cinquantaine de morts lors de cette
journée de 17 juillet 1791 alors à la
suite ça bah en fait sur les l'opinion
publique sur la presse
ce que l'on appelle la terreur tricolore
c'est à dire qu'un certain nombre de
journaux sont interdits et de
journalistes sont obligés de s'enfuir
comme mara par exemple finalement louis
saez doit se résoudre à accepter la
constitution
la première constitution de la france le
14 septembre 1791 il prête serment
devant l'assemblée c'est la fin de la
monarchie absolue le droit divin
elle fait place à une monarchie
constitutionnelle dans laquelle le roi
garde un certain nombre de pouvoirs
une nouvelle assemblée est ténue mais
uniquement par les citoyens aisés qui
paie un impôt le sens
cette situation provoque la rancoeur du
peuple d'un côté et celle du roi de lui
sortir le roi qu'est ce que tu en penses
toi si j'allais faire un tour à la cour
du roi
ça va mieux ferait une pique
vous avez raison je vais prendre l'air
[Musique]
dites donc mon cher lemoine ou direct le
roi dort sur ses deux oreilles en ce
moment vous avez plutôt bonne nîmes
non mais enfin je veux dire ça va plutôt
bien entre les députés le roi il ya plus
de problème
écoutez attendez moi une seconde je vais
porter ça au petit salon et je vais vous
expliquer quelque chose
qu'est-ce qui vous dire notre concours
que le roi l'ait utilisé son droit de
veto pour l'histoire des prêtres
réfractaires pour l'oeil quoi mais si
les révolutionnaires welt obliger tous
les prêtres a accepté la constitution
civile du clergé
si nos vies seront considérés comme
réfractaire enfin comme rebelle si vous
voulez mais à mon avis le roi ne signera
jamais ce décret il a toujours été du
côté du corps et comment vous savez tous
à vous quand on déshabille une reine
tous les soirs on finit par apprendre
des choses il donc ça réfléchit au petit
salon 1
on dirait complotent ces complots de
quoi va lui parler de guerre de guerre
devrait rentrer en qui on va t'expliquer
la guerre contre les autres monarchies
d'europe la prusse l'autriche et cette
guerre est bien notre bon roi parce
qu'ils pensent que notre armée
révolutionnaire va être battu par les
armées de ses bons amis comme ça il
pourrait récupérer son petit royaume et
continuer à bricoler ccme tranquille tu
as compris citoyens oui bon ça c'est pas
évident que tout comprendre d'un seul
coup un la demande à ton narrateur il a
expliqué jean-louis bandits vous avez
déjà vu l'émission
enfin bien sûr que nous aurons besoin
d'autant que lui bon ben vas-y explique
toi discrètement c'est malin tu m'as
fait repérer
en attendant sans moi tu seras un peu
perdus on t'explique la guerre menace
parce que les monarchies européennes
voient d'un très mauvais oeil cette
france turbulente
d'ailleurs certains révolutionnaires
français sont favorables à un conflit
pour porter la liberté la révolution aux
peuples d'europe
louis saez lui-même n'est pas opposé à
la guerre mais pour d'autres raisons
la guerre effectivement et voté le 20
avril 792 avec l'aval du roi qui peut
paraître surprenant puisqu'il déclare la
guerre à ses propres parents et à ses
soutiens on peut d'une certaine manière
mais oui elle sait très bien que en
déclarant la guerre est bien la
révolution risque de s'effondrer
en effet les réformes très nombreuses
qui sont enchaînés ont désorganisé en
grande partie entre au dollar mais il ya
une grande contestation qui s'est
développée entre 2 contre les officiers
d'origine aristocratique et donc louis
saez pense qu'en n'encourageant les
partisans de la guerre eh bien ils ont
entraîné l'effondrement gouvernement
révolutionnaire
les premières batailles sont
catastrophiques pour l'armée française
la tension monte dans la capitale
dès le 20 juin la foule rentrer dans les
tuileries et met mais un bonnet phrygien
sur la tête 2016
et puis des bruits courent comme quoi
louis saez et d'autres aristocratique
sont encore présents en france
comploterait avec les ennemis blanc la
déchéance du roi est à l'ordre du jour
mais coup de tonnerre le chef de l'armée
prussienne menace de décimer toute la
population parisienne
c'est le manifeste de breivik le 10 août
1792 tout bascule dans ton prend le
pouvoir l'hôtel de ville c'est la
commune insurrectionnelle de paris des
insurgés attaquent les huileries des
combats font plus de 1000 morts le roi
se réfugie auprès de l'assemblée
et puis donc la foule sont parfaitement
intégrés alors que le roi n'y est plus
et c'est à l'issue bien sûr de cet
épisode que finalement prend fin la
monarchie constitutionnelle et que la
révolution rendre une étape tout à fait
nouvelle et a beaucoup plus radicale est
entendue
louis saez et sa famille sont internés à
la prison du temple
cette fois c'est la fin de la monarchie
constitutionnelle quelques semaines plus
tard après la victoire de valmy en
septembre 1792 la première république
est proclamé sa première mission est de
régler le sort du rouge
[Musique]
bonjour là bonjour citoyens feraient
alors toujours en train de faire
campagne
je suis sûr qu'elle en train de vous
vendre les droits de la femme c'est ça
toujours aussi drôle hein la presse
ouverture du procès du roi mais figure
toi que je me suis proposé comme avocate
pour le roi mais il a préféré
malesherbes avocate du roi mais je te
croyais révolutionnaire c'est ça la
révolution le droit pour tous d'être
défendue devant les tribunaux même pour
le roi en attendant je crois qu'il va y
laisser des plumes
les plumes le chapon la tête le procès
du roi a lieu devant un tribunal bien
singulier ce sont les députés de la
convention la nouvelle assemblée qui le
juge
il s'agit donc d'un procès disons
politique le roi est accusé de
conspiration contre la sûreté de l'état
on a découvert dans son armoire de faire
des tuileries sa correspondance avec les
monarques européens mais aussi avec
certains de ses généraux sa condamnation
à mort est votée à une voix près 360 et
une pour 360 contre
louis saez et exécuté le 21 janvier 1793
place de la révolution
la reine marie-antoinette subira le même
sort neuf mois plus tard cette fois je
crois que c'est fini pour le roi plus
rien ne pourra le sauver
je pense à bord voilà c'est fini pour
tout cas c'était pas mon tour de passer
sur l'échafaud c'est incroyable la
réflexion des gens faudrait savoir ce
qu'ils veulent en tout cas la révolution
continue
et elle est loin d'être finie tiens à
fred on va faire une expérience à toi le
10 octobre 1793 expérience si tu veux
l'autre chose chantal me rappelle
pourquoi j'ai l'air malin je suis dans
rien mais non freine le 10 octobre 1793
ça n'existe plus le calendrier
révolutionnaire est entrée en vigueur
tu aurais dû te zapper le 19 vendémiaire
de l'an 2 elle est bien bonne
non mais tu crois qu'après faire ça m'a
fait j'essaye alors quoi de neuf depuis
la mort du roi là aujourd'hui le
gouvernement se déclare évolutionnaire
je peux t'en prendre un état grave a dit
révolutionnaire a commencé la révolution
tu as raison ça fait quatre ans depuis
septembre 1792 la france a même une
république
enfin façon de parler car en ce mois
d'octobre 1793 c'est la terreur qui est
à l'ordre du jour
les pouvoirs de l'état sont désormais
entre les mains des montagnards dont les
hommes forts sont robespierre danton
saint-just les montagnards qu'on appelle
ainsi parce qu'ils siègent en eau des
bancs de l'assemblée ont renversé les
girondins qui jusqu à présent gérer les
affaires de l'état
ces deux partis politiques si j'ose dire
sont composés de bourgeois mais ils
n'ont pas la même vision de la
révolution
les girondins sont des notables
provinciaux proche des milieux
d'affaires et du commerce
les montagnards s'appuie davantage sur
les classes populaires et la petite
bourgeoisie disant que les uns sont à
droite les autres à gauche cette
expression elle est née pendant la
révolution française car en effet il se
trouve que par coïncidence les plus
radicaux siéger à gauche alors que les
plus conservateurs siéger à droite et on
a maintenu bien sûr ces deux repères
pour désigner les partis politiques
jusqu'à nos jours
des affrontements entre les deux clans
ont été nombreux avec les girondins la
situation économique de la france était
désastreuse
le prix du blé ne cessé d'augmenter le
peuple est descendu dans la rue
dénonçant les spéculateurs et les
sans-culottes favorable aux montagnards
ont pris d'assaut l'assemblée la
convention en fait sous la pression
populaire va décréter l'arrestation
quelques dizaines de députés girondins
ils seront donc incarcéré certains
s'enfuiront en province se cacheront
pendant des mois et ce qu'ils y ont été
arrêtés seront exécutés en octobre 1793
c'est ainsi que les montagnards ont pris
le pouvoir mettant en place un nouveau
régime qui veut faire table rase du
passé
les révolutionnaires cherche établi une
contre-culture qui soit opposé la
culture bio soit reste aux pratiques
mais surtout à la culture religieuse qui
est condamné c'est pourquoi par exemple
robespierre on a cherché à substituer à
dieu un tube beaucoup plus vagues qu'il
va appeler l'être suprême robespierre se
méfie de l'athéisme dont il pense qu'il
pourrait effectivement créer une sorte
de la discipline tant qu il recherche
également un substitut à dieu on peut
signaler aussi les noms des saints qui
disparaissent
à la place ce sont des objets certains
certains perçoivent les brouettes porte
ou arrosoir puisque ce sont les termes
qui tu es désormais dans le calendrier
les moyens vont changer de nom apparaît
de thermidor de fructidor et puis pour
lutter contre ce qu'ils appellent les
ennemis de la révolution tant à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du pays
on met en place un gouvernement
révolutionnaire avec un comité de salut
public doté de pouvoirs exceptionnels
c'est le début de la terreur sois
prudent fred
bah il a plus personne ici excusez moi
vous n'avez pas vu mes copines citoyenne
et leurs amis non jeune homme depuis
longtemps et par les temps qui courent
et savoir ce qu'ils sont devenus
il demande est plutôt à monsieur là il
devait en savoir plus lui bonjour
monsieur
excusez moi de vous déranger je peux
m'asseoir votre table au principe du
jeune homme personne ne supporte ma
présence à sa table pourquoi vous dites
ça je le responsable de la bascule à
charlot la bascule à charlot jamais
entendu parler de ça la guillotine vous
connaissez le bourreau charlot c'est moi
un appel charles-henri sens où je
commence à comprendre mon cauchemar
dites moi comment vient bourreau ça se
transmet de père en fils figurez vous un
jour mon père devait exécuter une jeune
noble d'angélique
mon père il n'a pas plu mais vraiment
pas pu m'a dit pis il est temps pour toi
d'aidé temporaire et a ajouté ça devra
là bas j'avais 18 ans et vous en êtes
sortis trois fois j'ai dû m'y reprendre
ses deux premières ça provoque un
scandale c'est avec une épée à carla
l'eau parce qu'avant la guillotine
c'était l'épée le glaive lâche enfin
pour les nobles parce que les autres
c'était la corde les supplices d'accord
que les sales boulots a tué jeudi
jusqu'au xviiie siècle les bourreaux
sont tellement craint et indésirables
qu'ils devaient loger en dehors des
villes sous la terreur il y en a un par
département le nombre d'exécutions est
affolant ont guillotiné parfois jusqu'à
30 personnes par jour qu'elle
fréquentation et toi faut que je rentre
si j'ai une famille des petits bourgs à
nourrir mois et d'ailleurs ce soir ça va
encore être des patates des patates ça
ferait plaisir à parmentier 1
toujours est il que près-midi diot 10
des patates très des cartes et des
quinquas d'idées patassé des épées des
offres et des noms et des patates aussi
et des cannes et des caddies des patates
ont peur vous manger des patates dix
jours par semaine veut depuis leur
calendrier révolutionnaire avancé
seulement sept jours par semaine et
humide c'est pas mauvais les patates
ouais et le pain et le beurre c'est pas
mauvais non plus c'est pas la révolution
qui a rangé les choses et avec les
mauvaises récoltes de cette année et les
prix bas imposé par nos députés
ben les pays l'on garde en grains et par
un beau temps et pas de pain au chocolat
en tout cas à paris tout est rationnée
voilà la campagne ça va pas mieux non
plus j'ai entendu dire que beaucoup de
villes sont dans la guerre civile
lyon bordeaux marseille et j'en passe
toute façon les affaires vont mal un peu
partout
bien je te présente la bascule à charlot
enchanté excuse moi il faut que la chute
revient ce matin sur la place devrait
assister à l'exécution d'une femme bien
courageuse et puis à celle de toutes ses
amis les gens l'important femmes c'est à
dégoûter débours ryan tu m'excuses chs
faut que j'y aille
ça les corps seraient de m'appeler par
mon nom charles-henri chanson c'est
quand même pas compliqué
[Musique]
ariane je suis content de te voir j'ai
vraiment eu peur qu'il te sois arrivé
malheur ça comme tu vois si on veut
santé eh ben je préfère te voir ici qu'à
paris parce que tu sais que là bas les
têtes tombent les unes après les autres
et récemment j'ai eu vent qu'une femme
avait été guillotinés alors forcément
j'ai tout de suite pensé que c'était toi
c'était olympe mon ami son dernier
pamphlet lui a été fatal elle appelait
un référendum pour que les français
puissent choisir librement leur type de
gouvernement elle écarté provisoirement
la république centralisée et c'est la
république qui l'a définitivement écarté
on n'a rien pu faire
et ici ça se passe comment avec les
bleus comme vous les appelez comment
t'es pas au courant du dernier décret
que danton a fait voter quel décret la
réquisition trois cent mille hommes pour
partir en guerre contre l'autriche et la
puce il voulait les tirés au sort parmi
tous les hommes célibataires entre 18 et
40 ans on s'est pas passé comme ça les
hommes étaient pas d'accord qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait à cholet par exemple ils
ont résisté aux forces de l'ordre et
sont constitués en armée et aujourd'hui
il porte la cocarde blanche tu veux dire
celle de la monarchie salle de la
monarchie tu te rends compte c'est la
révolution contre la révolution
la raison il faut dire que depuis la
chute de la monarchie
la province a du mal à suivre les
événements qui se passent à paris en
vendée les paysans ont déjà été choqué
par l'exécution du roi et les mesures
contre le clergé la réquisition des
hommes pour la guerre est l'étincelle
qui embrase la région
les paysans se rebelle ils attaquent les
forces de l'ordre et se livre à quelques
massacres contre les partisans de la
révolution
c'est le début des guerres de vendée ils
ne savent pas se battre contre eux les
gardes nationaux par exemple qui
tiennent les villes et donc ils vont
aller chercher des nobles les
aristocrates qui sont tous pour la
plupart d'anciens militaires charrette
par exemple qui est un ancien militaire
néanmoins pour donner le change ont
choisi comme premier généralissime en
vendée un roturier qui s'appelle
cathelineau il sera donc un peu le
représentant bien de cette armée
catholique et royale car on se bat pour
le roi et pour la religion c'est armé
formé d'hommes inexpérimenté va pourtant
réussir à mettre l'armée républicaine en
déroute et à prendre le contrôle de
plusieurs villes
d'autres mouvements contre
révolutionnaires se développe dans le
midi en alsace en normandie ou encore en
bretagne où il prend le nom de schwann
riz à paris la convention prend un
décret qui condamne à mort les personnes
arborant la cocarde blanche puis pour
mater l'insurrection vendéenne
on envoie des soldats chargés de brûler
tous les villages on les appelle les
colonnes infernales l'après guerre de
vendée en fait va se termine en deux
temps tout d'abord premier épisode des
193 les environs dance ont vaincu à
savenay la guerre reprend tout de suite
après suite reconnaît infernal mais en
95 lorsque la terreur c'est sabari les
vendéens obtiennent du gouvernement
révolutionnaire et bien la possibilité
d'une part de ne plus partir à la guerre
et d'autre part que leur prêtre les
prêtres qui avait refusé de prêter
serment à la constitution puissent
retrouver leur poste a pas de ce moment
là les deux revendications essentielles
sont assez satisfaite et les 21 rentrer
chez eux
on estime que les guerres de vendée ont
fait entre 80 milles
deux cent mille morts qui rêve de toute
façon vous êtes gentils on se connaît on
sait déjà en contrôle plus de riz vous
étiez là servons de l'arn et oui avant
je les habille et la reine maintenant
c'est moi qu'on déshabille paul et tu
m'offres abois aller volontiers et
qu'est ce qu'il fait là c'est une boum
ils viennent de planter un arbre symbole
républicain de la liberté c'est ton
collègue lemoine là-bas et lemoine bien
voilà encore alors comme on l'a vu la
dernière fois elle très mal je vais très
très mal
napper au chômage technique n'est pas
madame madame n'a plus soif
c'est vrai que maintenant falloir penser
à être recyclé
normande retourner sa veste j'ai droit
du no rain vallée postuler chez les sans
culottes moi si ça continue avec imagine
que droit le dreknor de la liberté le
choc du coi animera le moral reste bon
les gendarmes derrière contre les
identités d'instaurer une sorte de carte
civique pour savoir qui lançait tu ne
l'as cannes est un désert bonjour
messieurs vos papiers s'il vous plaît
oui bien sûr tout de suite messieurs
voilà messieurs
c'est tout ce que j'aime
c'est pour agrémenter et puis la photo
d'identité en couleurs les 194 s'est dit
stop à cette enquête de suivi ce que je
veux voir aller sur le mode histoire et
lg journalistes dommage était ce un
passage à naga finir au tribunal
révolutionnaire
parlons-en du tribunal révolutionnaire
sous le régime de la terreur qui dit
suspect dit condamner à mort et les
suspects sont nombreux car la délation
est devenue une vertu il suffit parfois
d'être dénoncés pour être guillotiné
sans vrai procès
les vitrines d'eau qui souhaitent en des
lieux publics on peut donc participer au
jugement donc il ya une pression déjà de
la foule des 110 dates sont plutôt
extrémistes donc la peine qui est
souvent sollicité c'est la peine de mort
il y à un accusateur public à ses
célèbres il s'appelle antoine fouquier
tinville redoutable et bien entendu il
faut reconnaître que la défense des
accusés est très peu présente
ironie du sort ce qui ont instauré la
terreur vont eux mêmes être victime de
cette justice arbitraire et expéditive
le comité de salut public arrive ainsi à
éliminer hébert un révolutionnaire
extrémiste qui souhaitaient les mesures
les plus terroriste puis danton qui à
linverse souhaitait que le régime de la
terreur s'arrête
lors des procès durant lequel danton et
hébert seront condamnés on s'arrangera
pour mêler au sein des condamnés
d'autres condamnés qui n'ont rien à voir
pour faire une sorte d' amalgame
on met par exemple des vrais royalistes
en france pendant la terreur 17000
personnes sont guillotinés
vivant
[Musique]
citoyens alors on me dit que tu n'as pas
de papiers pote cocarde tombé j'ai rien
fait j'ai juste présenter ma carte
d'identité mais monsieur le procureur
tout ça c'est une blague
je ne sais pas ce que tu entends que
l'arm blague mais ici tu es dans un
tribunal révolutionnaire et citoyen je
crois que ton cas est désespéré d'accord
si je comprends bien
j'aurais dû venir avec ma tête sous moi
c'est ça m a c'est ça mon pote tu as
tout compris
allez au suivant otc ans
[Applaudissements]
mais
non
la terreur ne s'arrêtera qu'avec la
chute de robespierre le 9 thermidor en
deux l'incorruptible comme on l'appelle
et lipkin d'un complot monté par
d'autres montagnards partisans d'une
terreur à outrance mais qui craignaient
eux aussi de figurer sur la liste des
guillotinés les députés décrète alors
l'arrestation de robespierre qui sera
guillotiné dès le lendemain avec 21 de
ses partisans ainsi se termine la
période la plus terrible de la
révolution mais qui est sur certaines
idées fut sans doute aussi la plus
généreuse
c'est une époque où on voit apparaître
des mesures tout à fait étonnant tout à
fait spectaculaire même si elle ne l ne
suivront pas finalement leur cours c'est
par exemple la commission d esclavage
qui avait été refusé au début la
révolution parce qu'ils avaient des
intérêts dans les colonies c'est aussi
la loi dite du maximum ou au temps de
fixer les prix d'empêcher cette
inflation qui crée bien sûr des
conditions extrêmement difficiles au
sein du petit peuple de paris et l'on
voit apparaître des mesures qu'on
pourrait peut-être ap des mesures
sociales déjà finalement et on préfère
finalement prendre l'argent chez les
plus riches et tenter d'assurer je
dirais le minimum vital pour ce groupe
social qui est il faut lire quand même
le principal soutien du gouvernement
je comprends mon cauchemar maintenant
[Musique]
comment je vais me sortir dans cette
histoire-là mois chs non pas toi une
fois je trouve quelqu'un qui accepte
beau rabattables remets toi est-ce que
je peux formuler mes dernières volontés
dans cette situation c'est quoi tes
dernières volontés truqués dans la dot
derrière
[Musique]
appuyez sur le bouton rouge et or et
bien tu étais beau
[Musique]
dis donc tu t'en sors bien pas de
problème j'aime azza tête mais un jour
ça marchera pas bon pourquoi ça
marcherait pas à vérifier des piles au
moins par ta raison j'avais pas pensé à
tu vois tu aurais pu tomber en panne de
ville ah oui mais c'est mon chargeur à
parce que tu crois qu'il y avait de
l'électricité sous la révolution
française
ben non évidemment donc tu t'en sors
bien
il a toujours exemple
[Musique]